Homogeneous coordinates
We’ll start by recapping some fundamentals
of two-dimensional geometry. To start with,
we’re going to talk about a Euclidian plane.
A Euclidian plane is a non-curved surface
where the rules of Euclidian geometry apply.
We normally take this for granted.
We’re just going to be explicit about the
fact that we’re working with flat surfaces.
The second concept is Cartesian coordinates.
Again, this is a concept you should be well
familiar with. We have a set of orthogonal
axes typically labeled X and Y. We have a
point P and we describe its position with
respect to the origin in terms of distances
along the X and Y axes. A concept that is
perhaps less familiar to you will be homogenous
coordinates and we’re going to be using
them a lot in this lecture. Those of you who’ve
done the introduction to robotics course will
have already encountered homogenous coordinates.
To represent a point in a two-dimensional
Cartesian space, we describe it by a pair
of numbers written as tuple X, Y and we say
that this point lives in the space of two-dimensional
real numbers, which we denote by the symbol
R2 (R squared).
In homogenous coordinates, we represent the
same point with three numbers. In this case,
we’ve represent it as X, Y and the number
one. In fact, the number one is somewhat arbitrary;
it could be any non-zero constant. We say
now that this point belongs to the two-dimensional
projective space, which we denote by the symbol
P2 (P squared). So it’s the same point,
just two different ways to represent it. The
homogenous representation, the representation
in projective space is going to be very, very
handy to us in this lecture.
Now to convert from homogenous coordinate
to a Cartesian coordinate, I’m going to
start with the very general homogenous coordinate
denoted here as X tilde, Y tilde and Z tilde.
To convert it through a Cartesian coordinate
what I do is take the first two numbers and
divide by the third. So X and Y Cartesian
coordinates are given by X tilde on Z tilde
and Y tilde on Z tilde respectively.
Now a mathematician would say that in projective
space, lines and points have duals. They have
equivalent representations. Some very interesting
and very useful things flow from this duality.
We can write a line in homogenous form a little
bit different to what we’re used to but
we can write a line as three numbers denoted
here as L1, L2 and L3. Imagine that I’ve
got a point which moves along that line. So
the line is really the set of all possible
points that lie along it. I can express the
fact that the point lies on the line by the
dot product of the line and the point being
equal to zero. We refer to this as the point
equation of a line. A line is defined in terms
of all the points that could possibly lie
along it.
Now I can expand that out and we can see that
that looks a little bit different to the conventional
Cartesian representation of a line. But if
we do the transformation from homogenous coordinates
to Cartesian coordinates, we can show that
these two representations of a line are equivalent.
An advantage of using the homogenous form
is that it’s very easy to represent a line
that is vertical where in Cartesian coordinates,
that means that the grading of the line is
equal to infinity. In homogenous form, we
treat that situation very simply and conveniently.
We don’t need to introduce any infinities.
We also might be interested in how to describe
a line that joins two points. So here we have
two points and here’s a line that passes
through those two points. Then the homogenous
representation of the line which remember
is the three vector is given simply by the
cross-product of the two points that lie on
the line. So a very, very simple way of finding
the equation of a line that joins two points
much, much more conveniently than it is for
Cartesian coordinates.
We might also be interested in the problem
of the coordinate of the point at the intersection
of two lines. So here we have two lines and
this is the intersection point and the intersection
point is given by the cross-product of the
two lines. We call this the line equation
of a point. The point is defined in terms
of two lines.
So let’s create a point. A horizontal coordinate of
100. A vertical coordinate of 200. And points
are represented as Coulomb vectors. So that’s
a row vector that I’ve written just there,
so I will transpose it. So that will display
as a Coulomb vector. So this is a Euclidean
or Cartesian coordinate for a point.
Now we can convert the Euclidean coordinate
into a homogeneous coordinate using the function
e2h, and we can see that all it has done is
appended a 1 to it. So now instead of a vector
with two elements, its now a Coulomb vector
with three elements. The last element is a
one.
Now we can convert the homogeneous coordinate
back to a Euclidean coordinate by using the
inverse function h2e, for homogeneous to Euclidean, and I apply that to the answer
for the last operation and we see that it
is back now to a vector with two elements.
The result is the vector that we started with.